[Music]
this is a taxing bout set for one ball
with a 20-minute time limit
a percentage first at a combined weight
of 374 pounds
john silver and alex reynolds
and there we see joined by number five
and ten
of the dark order you have to imagine
that mr brodie lee is uh
is preparing his troops for that big
pay-per-view matchup coming up later
tonight
you know let's be honest that that mr
brodie lee
has intimidated these guys and
i don't know if i call him a bully or
not but he runs this
dark order and he makes sure that
everybody falls in line by fear rules by
fear very good
so these these guys reynolds and
silver they go into this thinking that
they got to win this match
[Music]
the mood's changing a little bit now and
their opponents from a location where
you need
an invitation at a combined weight of 24
ounces of vodka cranberry
isaiah cassidy mark quinn
private party
we saw on the graphic there tony party
has won two out of their last three
matches
they've been hovering around the number
five spock in the tag team ranked
for quite a while never really cracking
into the
upper echelon and this could be a
crucial crucial matchup for them
i think what we have seen from private
party excalibur
is the two young kids that i can call
them that they're not
neither one in their 30s has them yet
they haven't been together that long but
we have seen them
develop over the over the months here in
this first year
of aaw i mean they they had that major
upset against the young bucks in the
tournament
that really kicked off their confidence
and they've shown us a lot since then i
i'm just amazed when i look and see that
isaiah cassidy
is only 23 years old
he is the uh i believe the youngest
member of the aew
roster by by about a month riho right
behind him and jungle boy not far behind
there
how about them aren't shoes man wow
better not let taz
i know he'll he'll claim some sort of uh
trademark infringement as uh alex
excuse me john silver starts the match
with isaiah cassidy cassidy
has the arm of john silver number three
and the switch now silver with wrist
control yeah i'll tell you silver is
strong he's compact he's uh
he's saying built like a fire plug he's
just just
so solid and so strong and his kicks are
so
so deadly as uh as cody and matt cardona
found out when they faced three and four
on dynamite a couple weeks back
side headlock broken free by silver
and now the irish whip into the corner
sends cassidy
across floats up on over the top departs
right there from isaiah cassidy
and he's right there as soon as silver
turned around
like larry takes down john silver oh
he's faked
yeah reynolds good move that time and
and look at this mark quinn getting in
the ring doing his
his partner no favors distracting bryce
remsburg
and gwen saves double dropkicks there by
private party
i tell you sometimes uh being youthful
and being vibrant can work against you
and it worked really against
it worked against a private party there
momentarily but now they're back uh
back in control well you talked about
that uh that surprise
win they had over the young bucks in the
first round match of the aw world tag
team title tournament that happened all
the way back on october 9
2019 and uh there wasn't a lot of
footage
out there on private party it was tough
to research them the bucks were you know
just
launched dynamite on on tnt so they had
a lot of things in there uh
to worry about so private party caught
him by surprise but oh
great back up there by cassidy but once
the word was out on private party
a lot of teams seemed to catch up and
now they've been uh they've been trying
to fight back
up to that uh that advantageous position
they were in in early october
great tandem wrestling that time by
private party and i tell you they uh
they're looking for their eighth win as
a tag team but uh reynolds and silver
coming off of a win on our special
edition of dark that we had
just last night so that could help them
a great deal as far as momentum is
concerned
i really believe in momentum i really do
as far as rusty is concerned if you
start to win
you believe in yourself and that's one
of the things that dark order they
believe in themselves and they believe
in
in mr brodie lee or at least you start
to win and mr brodie stops yelling at
you yeah that's right that's a big
motivating
factor exactly oh flapjack bulldog
combination there by private party
cassidy getting in the face of john
silver one
and i i would argue that's the
inexperience of cassidy showing he
instead of going for the pinfall
he uh taunted his opponent and that that
kind of cost him
let's not forget at the top of the hour
we have
all out coming your way here live from
daley's place
that's eight o'clock you can still join
us cable satellite providers br live
fight.tv internationally
and there you see the matches that we're
going to have for you
oh wow silver covers with the far
leg and tony what about the aew women's
championship match
hikaru shida defending her title against
the nwa
world women's champion thunder rosso boy
did she look impressive on dynamite this
past wednesday
it was a tremendous match you're right
excalibur and and i've known thunder
roses for for many many years she is a
fighter
she is a talented young lady and it's
it's
even though that she just had some great
challenges you know
from the former women's champion nyla
rose i really think thunder rosa
represents one of her biggest challenges
ever yes stylistic nightmare
to say the least well for the aw women's
world champion
now dark order keeping cassidy isolated
in the corner keeping him away as far
away from his partner
as the ring will allow they're working
over his lower back driving their
shoulders
into that spine that that upper pelvic
region
and following up with the back breaker
is alex reynolds hook of the far leg
one shoot cassie able to kick free
not a bad move that time by reynolds
knock i
i like this i like when you don't get
the three count not the opponent if
you're close enough
knock his partner off the apron to be
able to continue with your office oh
inside cradle there one
two reynolds able to kick out
and does the smart thing dragon casting
in the corner using cassidy
clawing fighting his way and reynolds
just has to grab a knee bar to isolate
him to keep him down
silver covered but only got a two count
cassidy is uh he's been endured during
quite a bit of punishment here tonight
tony yeah
he really is and and you always should
as tag team
take one man and you don't have to plan
who that man is the beginning of the
match but
as the match goes and as the flow of the
match goes pick one man that you think
you can
you can work on and there are those
aforementioned kicks
of john silver so dangerous his legs so
powerful
he's strong man oh ran right into that
cover
one two now cassidy able to kick out
again that was close
and also coming up at all out the young
bucks will take on jurassic express
they were part of that big eight man tag
team match last wednesday night on
dynamite so were private party when they
teamed up with scu and we saw
we'll cover here cassie able to pick
free once again
we saw very very intense very motivated
young bucks and they they really
punished private party in that match
yeah they did and
they they've had a different attitude
and and i like the attitude and of
course
the attitude was because of what
happened with
hangman adam page and what happened with
the elite it's really giving them
a different type of attitude i like
being aggressive i've always liked that
and let's see what they're going to do
against jurassic express because this
match
for that match coming up tonight very
very important
fans you only have 10 minutes we
understand to to join us
for all out of night 10 minutes we'll
take the air live
all out here daley's place and need to
say this is a
this is a comment i was saying people go
duh but it's been a very interesting
year right
but it's great it's it's great to see
fans come back
you know we it's a it's a small audience
here everybody is uh
social distancing with a mask on but
it's great to see fans come back
and be a part of this shout out uh kudos
to the
aew live events team doing great work
making sure everybody's staying safe
socially distanced here
and thank you also to the staff here at
uh daley's place
really been been great hosts great
partners with us and uh can't say enough
about them
talk about great partners isaiah cassidy
would like nothing more than tag and his
great partner mark quinn does so right
now
[Applause]
gwen clothesline takes silver off his
feet second one
looking perhaps for the trifecta nope
back buddy drop
king's turn around manhattan dropped
there on john
silver beautiful dropkick takes silver
off his feet
and the clothesline sends reynolds out
to the outside
gets the boot up he staggers silver back
towards
center moon salt press one two
no reynolds in time to break it up
now this is where this is where it's
really dangerous for private party
now it's broken down here a little bit
it's gotten to a brawl
and private party desperately need this
win
but silver and reynolds desperately need
to not be yelled at by mr brody lee
absolutely and now oh
a little bit of a miscommunication oh
they went for a silly string
well scouted that time as well oh man
thunder is boot to the back of the head
silver has quinn up on his shoulders
spin some pins on one two oh
wow everyone here thought that was it
and so did john silver referee bryce
remsburg hand
a hare's breath away from the mat
counting the three count
john silver needs to capitalize on this
momentum tony
[Applause]
and just as i say that he tags in
reynolds who drops off the cricket
that's right
well he's going to go down and uh try to
get isaiah cassidy
you know sometimes you get into the you
know as well as anybody else excalibur
you get into a match you get angry
and you change directions and you just
you let
your anger get the best of you
everybody's got a game plan until they
get punched in the face
exactly and now dark order with both
members private party up on top but dark
order get knocked back into the ring
private party sat down at comic-con 450
splash but silver got the knees up
reynolds avoided the 450. with that one
god that foot caught him
rolling elbow stuff up as he goes
how did he get out of that
they hit him with everything that time
and he still escaped
how tough our private party
[Applause]
wow that was something
[Applause]
well if you're liking this the action
will continue at the top of the hour
all out on pay-per-view cable and
satellite providers order it now
on vr live or fight tv internationally
you do not
want to miss it and
dark order they're setting up for that
that flipping ddt that's how they won
their match last night on dark
but isaiah cassidy able to avoid that
pele kicked there by quinn
rock silver silver got his arm up though
i don't think it found the effect it
wanted because silver got the arm of it
still
him he almost almost knocked his arm
back into his own head
wow those powerful legs of silver there
he got the boot up
get both legs up cassidy goes off the
back of quinn quinn
janet juice that that could be it well
he's back
three that is that what
oh what is in this match private party
i'm surprised he didn't really make the
cover immediately excalibur because of
his back
his lower back but he was still able to
circle around and
pin the shoulders down and get the win
that was a fantastic tag team match
a tremendous tag team match and i
mentioned how
private parties been hovering around
number five they are
they have a chance to crack the top five
next week
and they could be facing either kenny
omega and heckman adam paige
or fcr at some point in the near future
here it is once again great camera shot
here a
gin and juice getting juice what's the
cover see you
his back goes around still makes it up
yeah when he flipped up
to hit that cutter i think his back
might have spasmed when he hit the
canvas that caused a momentary delay but
luckily enough
for private party that did not cost them
the victory